E aí
[Música]
e a consciência logia ela é uma ciência
criada pelo professor Waldo Vieira
através da consciência logia a gente
estuda todos os corpos que se manifestam
a nossa consciência a nossa consciência
é a nossa alma o nosso espírito aquilo
que for melhor para sua procriação
pessoal através da consciência logia
existe uma teoria que a teoria da
descrença então eu quero dizer a vocês
não acreditem em nenhuma palavra que eu
vou dizer aqui em absolutamente nada
toda a verdade com um ponto final é uma
crença e crenças limitam mais
experiências libertam então tenho vocês
suas próprias experiências eu vou me
apropriar um pouco do inverno para poder
fazer uma analogia a hibernação dos
animais eu vou fazer uma analogia a
natureza esse momento em que os ursos e
muitos a
e para dentro das suas cavernas para
poder fazer em aquele movimento de
sustentabilidade das próprias energias
para saírem desbravarem o viver
desbravarem a própria sustentabilidade
estou chamando esse momento de inverno
consciencial e aqui também eu vou fazer
uma analogia o inverno consciencial ao
momento em que a gente está dentro do
útero do útero da nossa mãe essa
abordagem é uma abordagem praticada pela
professora Maria Auxiliadora Souza
Brasil em que ela vai dizer que muitos
de nós desenvolvemos a ilusão do Paraíso
desenvolvemos a ilusão do gratuito a
ilusão do contato com os nossos pais e
por que que eu estou falando dos nossos
pais porque quem de vocês além de mim
tem questões com os próprios pais quem
sente dor nessa relação quem sente um
o filme em relação ao pai e a mãe quem
coloca os pais muitas das vezes no
pedestal
e assim como vocês eu também sinto esse
tipo de relacionamento com os meus pais
e pela minha própria experiência eu
busco a minha autonomia e um pouco sobre
isso que eu quero falar com vocês hoje
dentro dessa abordagem a professora vai
dizer que o momento que a gente sai do
útero no momento que o cordão é cortado
a gente entra na nossa primeira dor que
é a dor do existir a dor da angústia
nesse momento específico eu começo a
atribuir a essa dor buscando o paraíso
buscando os meus pais nas coisas e nas
pessoas esse tipo de condicionamento ele
nos levam algumas posturas e eu vou
falar sobre duas posturas específicas a
primeira delas se relaciona a Quem não
chora não mama Essa é o tipo de postura
daquelas pessoas que são vítimas e se
posicionam perante a vida criando
e até já cê fazendo toda uma logística
teatral e de teatro eu sei bem muitas
das vezes eu usei desse atributo também
a gente usa de todo uma estratégia
teatral para ser o SIM para conseguir o
que queremos e nesse movimento a gente
vai criando e desprendendo energia para
termos o sim em uma estratégia de
sobrevivência e numa estratégia de
comodidade ou está um exemplo bem
simples muitas pessoas já me ouviram
falar sobre esse exemplo eu acordo de
manhã querendo tomar sorvete mas eu não
tenho dinheiro para tomá-lo eu não tenho
como exercer o meu direito sobre o meu
próprio desejo então o que que eu faço
eu pego ali as pessoas da minha
convivência e começa a dizer Nossa que
vontade de tomar um sorvete nossa eu
acordei com a boca guarda de vontade de
tomar sorvete e eu vou atribuindo ao
outro o meu próprio de
e ao final do dia depois de muito
esforço alguém vira para me diz assim eu
não vou te dar e nesse momento eu fico
com muita raiva muita raiva e aí eu
quero dizer a vocês que vocês devem
fazer as pazes com a própria raiva
porque a raiva ela é um sinalizador que
o gratuito e o paraíso aqui
personificado pelos nossos pais não
existe infelizmente colocar a vida na
mão do outro não é um bom negócio A
raiva é cuspir para cima se eu tivesse
autonomia para comprar o meu próprio
sorvete ou para sair da minha casa e
acesso a sorveteria eu não precisaria
atribuir o meu desejo ao outro e
realmente esse não é um bom negócio
é através da abordagem da
conscienciologia como eu já disse
através da abordagem da professora Maria
Auxiliadora Brasil na sua terapia
fenomenológica existencial e através
também dos estudos do professor best
Hair através das constelações familiares
através da minha própria experiência
pessoal através dos atendimentos que
realizo a maioria das pessoas têm muito
conflitos com os pais muitos conflitos
EA partir desses conflitos emergem toda
a dor e eu vou transferindo
responsabilidades o tempo todo a segunda
abordagem é Eu só sou feliz com você Eu
só sou feliz com meu marido sua feliz
como esposa eu sou feliz trabalhando eu
sou feliz transando eu sou feliz me
drogando eu sou só feliz me alimentando
E por aí vai uma gama de transferência
de responsabilidades mas eu descobri
através dessas teorias todas que ninguém
o nosso por acaso todas as pessoas tem
um propósito e aqui eu convido a vocês a
pararem de criticar os seus pais a
pararem de colocar em seus pais dos no
pedestal se pai e mãe fossem atributo de
seguridad de afeto de carinho Imagine o
que seria das pessoas que nasceram
vítimas distúrbio e foram abandonadas
pelos seus pais que foram colocados na
lixeira seriam dessas pessoas em grande
maioria são pessoas que fazem a
diferença porque descobriram desde muito
cedo que estão aqui para constituírem a
própria autonomia E aí muitos devem
estar se perguntando Paola Mas por que
servem os pais então para que servem os
pais se eu estou aqui para o
desenvolvimento da minha própria
autonomia os pais são Portal um portal
para minha própria autonomia é através
deles que eu estou
Oi e a vida está a meu serviço a vida é
um presente um presente para nossa
existência para a nossa própria
autonomia e eu convido vocês a fazerem
exercícios por como eu já disse aqui o
gratuito não existe o paraíso não existe
a vida nos compete o trabalho Cabe a mim
mesma então Quais são esses exercícios
você vai pegar um caderno e vai escrever
a sua história você vai escrever a sua
história e vai colocar todos os
atributos positivos e negativos em
relação seu próprio viver vai dizer um
sim a vida um sim ao seu pai um sim a
sua mãe hum sim ao seu pai EA sua mãe
que você não conheceu um fim a esse
Portal Divino que te coloca aqui para a
vida se colocar a serviço de você
Imaginem O que são 9 bilhões de pessoas
vivendo nesse planeta conectadas a
serviços umas
e sucessivamente essa engenharia uma
diário muito perfeita muito bonita Então
eu quero convidar vocês a escreverem
essa história a contarem para vocês
mesmos e vocês perceberem todos os
atributos positivos e negativos que te
fazem ser o ser humano que você
o outro exercício muito importante
também a ser feito pega a sua criança
ferida aquela parte sua que ainda busca
o paraíso que ainda busca o útero e que
ainda busca os pais que busca o gratuito
mini a sua criança e diga a ela com todo
amor com todo alto amor eu sinto muito
minha linda Sinto muito mas eu sou a sua
única realidade o resto é ilusão
obrigado